Hi. I'm here to talk to you about time, but
before we begin let me make one announcement,
recently there is a huge popularity in conference
talks, I have to tell you one thing, this
talk, this thing doesn't work I'm sorry, popularity
in animated GIFs as conference talks.
Oh I'm sorry, yes, it's gone. I'm so sorry.
This has never happened before. I'm sorry.
Let's try once again, I'm sorry.
Yes.
FROM THE FLOOR: Hooray!!  .
YES!! Animated gifs, this talk is totally
and 100% animated gifs free! As part of that
we have rehearsed this talk has never been
tested on animals, you can consume this talk
and apply it whenever you want.
Now, let's begin in 1742 Benjamin Franklin,
in his book writes, "Remember that time is
money." This still proves today in digital
reality of 2015.
Recent research shows that site loading in
one second compared to a site that closes
in 3 seconds as 50% lower bounce rate, 22%
higher conversion rate. This is a lot. Another
research shows that for every second of performance
improvement for Wal-Mart.com they gave 2%
in conversion rate, doesn't sound that much,
now we are talking about a company with 482
billion dollars in annual revenue from e-commerce,
now we're talking about a lot of money. Firefox
made research and figured out that for shaving
off 2.2 seconds from the Firefox browser download
page would give them 15.4% in conversion rate
that would result in more than 10m down loads
per year more. This is huge, so time matters.
Performance matters. There is one issue though,
statistics that uses these numbers leaves
out one important thing, the users don't really
care about statistics. .
Users, our main stakeholders who give us money,
who give us down loads, they don't care about
absolute numbers in seconds, milliseconds,
number of down loads and so on and so on.
Let me give you one example, here is a site
the title of which I deliberately hide, but
we can see that it is visually complete in
more than five seconds, we know it happens
only after 8 seconds. This is crazy, people,
if we were using only statistics we would
say this site is in desperate need or performance
improvement, but would you be surprised if
I tell you this is a site that has 89 billion
US dollars in revenue any way, you know why?
It's Amazon.com.
Using these statistics we would, we could
conclude there is a crisis out there, but
fear not, let's see how this site works in
a real browser.
We type in URL and this site is almost instantly
here. So, why does this happen? Statistics
tells us a different story, because performance
is not about statistics. Even though being
an essential part of what we call 'Performance
now' absolute numbers do not define performance
site, performance is not maths, it's about
perception.
Today, I am not going to tell you how to shave
off milliseconds of your page loading times,
I'm not going to tell you about absolute numbers
of time at all, instead I will give you a
little bit different perspective on performance,
I will tell you, using some simple but very
effective techniques, how to manage users
perceptions. Time, as we perceive it in our
brains, sometimes it's completely different
to the time that we can watch on the stop
watch.
To help us in this journey we will employ
the most powerful tool that we have at our
disposal, being our brain. This is the tool
where all the illusions of time happen.
Before we begin I might tell you a shocking
truth not all your optimisation techniques
and results can be even noticeable by a user.
In the
19th Century, German practical psychologist
Weber and later his student postulated a law
that is now called Weber-Fechner law, the
just noticeable differences between the two
stimuli, time is no exception to this law,
this law can be applied to our durations.
Let's imagine we have a duration, any duration
and the law says that there is a certain value,
JND, that is a constant coefficient of this
duration, no matter what duration you have.
Experiments show that for small periods of
times, less than 30 seconds, these there are
times that we, as web developers are particularly
interested in, for this short of time, the
Weber law can be approximated to a simple
20% rule. What does it mean? Let's say you
have a page that is down loading in 2 seconds,
in order for your user to just notice any
difference in time you have to make your page
faster in 2 seconds minus 20% being 1.6 seconds,
so if your page downloading slower than 1.6
seconds the users don't notice the difference,
so why do we spend so much time dealing with
a tiny bit of milliseconds because users just
don't notice it.
Another thing is that 20% can be used as for
performance optimisation but it can also be
used for regression allowance. For example,
you deploy a feature to your site or your
product that slows done your site. Applying
this 20% rule you can figure out your users
will even notice this difference. If, for
example, your regression is 15%, you just
push the feature, forget about it and keep
going. You don't need to make your site as
fast as it was before the feature, users just
don't notice the difference, this is psychology.
There is one catch in this rule though, we
are talking about 'Noticeable', difference.
Noticeable doesn't mean meaningful. In order
for users to appreciate the optimisations
that you do, you have to go way beyond the
20% threshold.
To understand how our brain perceives time
we need to figure out some properties of this
time. In 20th Century philosophy Martin Heidegger,
in this book being on time, writes this, "Time
persists merely as the consequence of the
events taking place in space", so time and
events.
According to Heidegger, time consists of nearest
events and has beginning and end. All the
events within this time have their beginning
and end as well, as long as we don't have
any hard core philosophers in this room, we
might agree with this.
For the sake of this talk, we'll call the
beginning of the event 'Start event marker',
at the moment one event is over, we'll call
it 'End event marker", so start and end event
marker. Another property of almost every event,
every event has active phase and passive phase,
active phase is when your brain is mentally
active, it doesn't mean how active, it might
be pure mental activity, it might be related
to physical activity, but your brain is busy
doing something. In passive phase your brain
has no other option other than just wait for
the event to be over. We can, using different
techniques, manipulate how long are these
phases. Thus manage the wait. The problem
is that this passive part is the most dangerous
thing, this is when people complain about
long waits, they mean exactly this, because
active phase usually is not perceived as a
wait at all for people, they're busy. Research
at
MIT but Richard Lawson shows that people in
passive wait over estimate the time waiting
by 36%, this is a lot. Active and passive
phase, the third most important thing about
wait advance is that people just hate passive
wait. This is essential. People hate this.
We all might agree with this. There are multiple
techniques to manage this perception of events.
We can, using this information I gave you,
consider that in order to reduce this so hated
passive wait we have to increase the active
phase of every event, then people will consider
that that event takes less time than it actually
does. All the techniques for managing this
boil down to two simple once, the first one
being pre-emptive start, in this case we deal
with only one start event marker, somehow
we should move this marker in user's perception,
closer to the end. Since we don't do anything
to the original event time, we just do this
in the user's brain, what happens in this
last, in this part? Well, some sort of magic,
or rather something that your users don't
need to know about. Let's see some examples.
In 2009, research of Houston airport started
getting an interesting and unusual type of
complaints, people were not satisfied with
long baggage handling times. So administration
decided ok we will help people and they increased
the number of handlers on the baggage line,
that dropped the overall time of handling
to eight minutes, anybody who is travelling
knows that eight minutes from the moment you
leave the plane to the moment you get the
bags on carousel is not that mean, in Manchester
the fast time in UK, 6.5 minutes, surprisingly
enough the number of complaints didn't drop.
Administration decided to investigate the
problem, they figured out yes indeed the overall
handling time is eight minutes, in order to
get from the aeroplane to the baggage carousel
for the average person requires 1 minute,
the rest of the seven minutes the person stands
there waiting for his bags to show up.
Employing the pre-emptive start technique,
administration came out with a really simple,
but very effective solution, what they did
they started routing the planes to a terminal
further from the baggage carousel now it takes
an average person 6 minutes to go from the
plane to the baggage carousel six minutes
and then two minutes waiting for the bag.
So instead of one minute of active phase they
gave passengers 6 minutes of active phase.
Instead of 7 minutes of waiting, they gave
them only 2 minutes of passive waiting. Guess
what, the number of complaints dropped to
zero. People didn't mind going longer, they
just didn't want to stand and wait.
This is off line, do we have examples closer
to online we are front line developers. We
have example with the, safari has pre-load
top hits, how does it work, you type in the
URL in the browser and you get this 'Top hits'
thing at the top, if you didn't disable it
deliberately. What is it? While you are typing
your URL, safari tries to guess what page,
based on your history, what page are you trying
to reach. While you are typing your URL safari
is already pre-downloading this page for you,
so then when you click, "Go", your page is
here almost instantly. While you are typing
the URL safari is pre-loading the page, the
same browser opening the new tab. You click
on the link, choose,
"Open a new tab", sometimes animation and
then the page is loaded. If we get into this
tabs animation a bit closer, we will notice,
I don't know whether everybody sees here,
but there is this short blue line indicating
that the page is in the downloading process
already. So if we - while the animation progresses,
this bar is progressing as well, why you are
enjoying the animation of the tabs, this site
is downloading to deliver to you as soon as
possible, preferably right thereafter animation
is over.
In our work we are starting getting this fancy,
prefix, all the attributes that help us speed
up our sites as well. They even go being a
technical solution they aim for the same thing
that I was telling you, to reduce the passive
wait by increasing the active wait for you.
While you are downloading a page these attributes
are already pre-loading resources you might
need on the next page, with that reducing
your passive wait time when you get to those
pages.
So, in the pre-emptive start technique, it
all starts with the active phase and then
short passive wait at the end. Similarly to
this, we can have early completion technique,
where we deal now with end event marker that
we shift, somehow, in users' mind closer to
the beginning and have it right there at the
end.
A good example of this technique is pretty
much any video streaming service like YouTube
for example, it all starts with a passive
wait. If you click the play button the spinner
is showing up to indicate that the video is
in downloading process. So you are in passive
wait you have nothing else to do you just
sit and wait, but then, once the first possible
to view chunk of the video is downloaded it
starts playing in your video player, hence
switching you to the active phase because
your brain now is busy watching the downloaded
part while the original event of downloading
the whole movie is still in progress in the
background. You just don't mind because your
brains busy. So we start with short passive
wait, and switch user to the active phase
as soon as possible. Let's get back to our
Amazon example but now with DevTools. In particularly
we're interested in the timeline. If you want
to analyse Amazon.com all the essential assets
required to render the top of the page that
is visible to user immediately, these assets
like images and CSS and text are ready in
less than a second. They are ready to be rendered
and they are rendered. This is what happens
when this assets are rendered on the screen
user is switched from passive phase of the
wait, all the way to activated because there
is something on the screen that users can
on assume already. They don't care whether
it's 5 or 6 or 7 seconds after this switch
the page is keeps downloading this is where
statistics doesn't give us real picture of
how users perceive your sites.
This is great where you have active phase,
but what happens if for example your event
doesn't have obvious active phase. Well we
create one. In the beginning of 20th century
managers of sky scrapers and high buildings
in US started getting a lot of people living
in these buildings on long waiting for the
elevators. Long wait times so people had to
wait for 10, 15 minutes to get to elevator
during the rush hours, and of course they
were a bit
nervous when they were rushing to work or
something. There was no technical solution,
no easy technical solution you cannot build
more elevators in existing buildings you cannot
also tear down the building and build a new
one with 5 levels. From here the story diverges.
Designers say it was a designer, but engineer
say it was an engineer, but support somebody
came up with an idea and the idea was mirrors.
Mirrors all the way from the floor to ceiling
in the lobby where people are waiting for
the elevator itself, and guess what, after
that the number of complaints dropped to zero.
What happened?
Before mirrors the whole process of waiting
for an elevator was pure passive wait there's
no active phase, people had to stand and wait
for the elevator. With employing the windows
we switch the whole passive wait into the
active phase, because people looking at the
mirror they keep their brain busy they look
at themselves before going to work they look
how they look like after the hard day working
they peek at each other secretly and their
brain is busy.
Long after this story, many years after that,
some of us still use mirrors to entertain
their brain.  to conclude this,
I would tell you that modern front-end developer
should always consider performance, but performance
with only technical means is just simply not
enough. Modern front-end developers have to
be technicians, they have to be psychologist
and a little about of magician. We should
show the user what they want to see while
doing the real job behind the stage. Good
developer knows how to build fast website,
excellent developer knows how to make user
believe that the site is fast enough for them.
With this, we have reached the end event marker
of this talk. Thank you.